the Philippines has a problem on top of
fighting the spread of the corona virus
hospitals are facing another crisis they
are more than 20,000 nurses short but
the thing is tens of thousands of nurses
graduate every year in the Philippines
this 2010 oath-taking ceremony included
more than 35,000 graduating nurses and
this is a graduating class from 2017 and
this one is from 2019 so how can the
Philippines have so many nurses and be
dealing with a shortage at the same time
[Music]
this story starts in 1898 when the
Philippines became a u.s. colony
Filipinos fought back but were
ultimately conquered by American troops
more than 200,000 Filipinos diet as part
of the colonization of the Philippines
the u.s. created a policy called
benevolent assimilation that claimed to
protect Filipino rights and liberties
they use this to justify the
colonization of the Philippines by
arguing that this was a different kind
of colonialism and imperialism this was
a good kind of colonialism that would
bring education infrastructure and
public health the u.s. started taking
over institutions and education and
began developing a medical labor force
in the Philippines
they built more than 10 nursing schools
in less than a decade Filipino nursing
students had to learn Western medical
practices from American teachers and
they were forced to learn in English
year after year new classes of American
trained English speaking Filipino nurses
graduated from nursing schools what this
did was that it inadvertently prepared
Filipino nurses to work in the United
States the nursing training system went
on until the Philippines gained
independence in 1946 but even though the
Philippines broke free America soon
found a way to bring Filipino nurses
over starting in 1941 after the u.s.
entered World War two millions of
Americans joined the Armed Forces and
thousands of nurses enlisted to treat
injured soldiers in the field and
American hospitals started emptying out
so the government funded programs like
the cadet Nurse Corps to fill the gaps
they provided millions of dollars for a
lifetime education for free and
encouraged American women in particular
to enlist in a proud profession as a
result nearly 200,000 American women
became nurses for the army and civilian
hospitals with the same purpose to ease
the pain of war to help save lives but
that all changed in 1945 when the war
came to an end
once the fighting was over there was
less support for nurses government
funding dried up and many women quit
nursing hospitals started seeing a rise
in vacancies and that meant America
needed to find nurses to fill the void
again instead of improving pay and
working conditions to encourage American
nurses to return the u.s. looked beyond
its borders to fill the jobs Americans
wouldn't take and it turned to a new
temporary visitors program as a solution
US hospitals started to use the exchange
reserve program in order to recruit
Filipino nurses because they had
Americanized nursing training already
and it worked
Filipino nurses dominated the program
for about a decade more than 10,000
Filipino nurses came to the u.s. to work
but the real reason so many left their
homes has to do with what was happening
in the Philippines at the time after
centuries of oppressive colonial control
and their own world war two battles the
Philippines economy finally started to
stabilize cities were flourishing and
tourism was booming but wages
particularly in rural areas were still
low for nearly everyone and that
included nurses who despite having
formal training were often paid less
than janitors or messengers and that
pushed many to go abroad in search of
better opportunities but when they came
over to the u.s. many sponsoring
hospitals just used them as an expensive
labor they assigned them extensive nurse
work and only paid them a minimal
stipend after their temporary placements
ended many Filipino nurses went back to
the Philippines while many others
managed to stay longer and build a life
in the US were they formed strong
Filipino communities but the exchange
visitor program wasn't the end of
America's hold on Filipino nurses it was
just the beginning the 1960s brought big
changes to America there are certain
historical events new Great Society
programs such as the establishment of
Medicare and Medicaid there are civil
rights and
social movements American women have
more opportunities to enter other kinds
of occupations all of these things
converge to increase the demand for
nursing services but also to result in
even more nursing shortages in the
United States in just three years
nurse vacancies nearly doubled nearly
one in every four nursing jobs was
vacant to fill the new shortage the u.s.
turned to the Philippines once again but
this time it was different immigration
policy in America changed drastically in
1965 with the new Immigration and
Nationality Act for the first time
people from all over the world could
apply for immigrant visas then on top of
sponsoring hospitals labor recruiters
and travel agencies started targeting
Filipino nurses with ads that promised
them bright futures in America one
particular ad featured a basket that was
decorated with the Philippine flag it's
addressing the Filipino nurse saying
dear nurse if you're not happy where you
are right now contact us and we can't
promise you happiness but we can help
you chase it all over the place so
Filipino nurses began filling the huge
shortages all around the US but soon
many experienced discrimination the
American nurse Association added
licensing requirements to limit their
entry the nurses who did pass those
requirements came to the US and ended up
in underpaid lower positions still it's
this phase of migration that lasted
through today and transformed the u.s.
healthcare industry the temporary
pathway established 20 years earlier
became a permanent migration route and
the hospitals now had a way to learn
nurses over whenever they wanted but
focusing on what pulled so many nurses
to America overlooks the forces that
continued to push them out which brings
us back to the Philippines this is
Ferdinand Marcos who rule the
Philippines with an iron fist
in 1972 under martial law he began to
rule as a dictator he was behind more
than 3000 extrajudicial killings and
tens of thousands of tortures and
incarcerations
as a result of the unrest the economy
that was starting to stabilize fell into
a recession and unemployment skyrocketed
but instead of addressing the lack of
jobs the Philippine government actively
promoted and publicized labor export the
export of Filipino workers to countries
throughout the world and that's because
Filipino overseas workers were starting
to send hundreds of millions of dollars
back home to their families and the
Filipino government wanted to keep that
money coming overtime that government
push led to a global migration making
the Philippines the largest exporter of
nurses in the world nearly 20,000 nurses
leave the Philippines every year they go
to Saudi Arabia or Australia the UK
Germany but many of them have ended up
in the US where nearly one-third of all
foreign-born nurses are Filipino with
the u.s. recruiting nurses on one end
and the Philippines pushing them to work
abroad on the other both governments
have benefited from Filipino labor over
the decades a total of a hundred and
fifty thousand Filipino nurses have come
to work in US hospitals and after years
of exploitation and discrimination
Filipino and Filipino American nurses
have organized in the u.s. they pushed
back on exploitative practices and have
fought for better working conditions but
surveys show that a large number of
Filipino nurses are still concentrated
in bedside and critical care some of the
most dangerous and strenuous nursing
work
it's the kind of work that puts them
disproportionately on the front lines of
the fight against the coronavirus the
pandemic has taken an outsized toll on
Filipino health care workers of the 318
healthcare workers lost to the corona
virus as of May at least 30 are Filipino
and still thousands remain on the
frontlines in April 2020 as a corona
virus spread through the Philippines and
the shortage of nurses across hospitals
became a problem the government
temporarily banned healthcare workers
from leaving to work abroad while it
might seem like a appropriate idea for
Filipino nurses to remain in the
Philippines it's also important to
remember that Filipino nurse oversees
migration is a long-standing phenomenon
that has been actively promoted by the
Philippine government even though the
ban was eventually lifted it points to
the instability that Filipino nurses
have to live with on both sides of the
migration route pushed and pulled
between countries Filipino nurses
continue to get caught in the middle
even as they strive to work on the front
lines providing critical care like they
always have
[Music]